أظن
أجنبيًا ، ماذا عندما غادروا كانوا يبحثون عن
الخصوصية والابتعاد عن كل
الصحافة واهتمام المصورين
وأي رغبات سيئة وربما ينبغي عليهم
فعل ذلك ، أعني أنهم على ما يبدو قد
استغلوا للتو المزيد من الدعاية أكثر مما
يفعلون  سبق لك أن حصلت على العضوية كعضو في
العائلة المالكة في المملكة المتحدة ، لذا أتمنى لهم
التوفيق ، لكنني أعتقد أنهم بحاجة فقط إلى
اتباع نصائحهم الخاصة وأنت تعرف
نوعًا من العيش بشكل خاص
[موسيقى]
ليس لدي أي اهتمام بهاري ميغان
لقد عزلوا  الكثير من الناس
هنا يسمحون لهم بالذهاب والعيش في
أمريكا بقدر ما أشعر بالقلق ، فأنا
بالتأكيد لن أشاهد المسلسل
الذي أخشى أن يكون
هذا بقدر ما أفكر فيه ،
فأنا لا أعرف  أقضي الكثير من الوقت في
ذلك حقًا ،
فأنا لا أزعج نفسي بالقراءة خارج
العنوان ، أعتقد أن
نوعًا ما من شؤون الأسرة والمسائل الشخصية ،
لكن في نوع من الأماكن العامة
ليس لدي الكثير من الوقت
لأكون صريحًا ولا أحد يرى ما يحدث
خلف الأبواب المغلقة
الجدل ليس جو  st تتعلق
بإنجلترا ولكنها تشبه
الجدل العالمي لأن العائلات المالكة
متورطة في كل مكان وأنهم
يخرجون منها ويخرجون في
الأماكن العامة هو شيء
أتطلع إليه كثيرًا ، لقد رأيت مقطورات منه
، لقد رأيت كيف  هل يمكنني أن أقول تصريحات
هاري وميغان عندما يشرحون
سبب تنحيهم عن السلطة ، فأنا فضولي للغاية لأن
العائلة المالكة
لم تكن الأعمال شفافة
جدًا للجمهور ، أنا مدافع كبير عن
العائلة المالكة ، إنه أفضل شيء في
هذه البلدان على الإطلاق  لدي وأشعر بذلك في
النهاية